[Music]
I'm guessing that there are three types
of people here one you're an existing
chrome customer here to kind of just
share the joys the tribulations of going
on this chrome journey so we're gonna
get a lot of that here with our
panelists today I'm guessing a second
group you've heard of chrome you're
starting to maybe pilot or do a POC on
it and you just want to find out more
and see what that path looks like as we
move ahead and we'll definitely get some
of that going some of those questions
answered we're gonna have a Dory open as
well so you can ask questions throughout
the session as we progress and then I'm
guessing and you don't need to identify
yourselves but there's probably a third
group of you who's just tired of going
to a session I've talked about
kubernetes containers cloud machine
learning AI totally fine we welcome you
here today to to to take a break from
the cloud topic as well but hopefully
you'll leave from this session having
learned a bit about Chrome and what it
takes to deploy Chrome and what it looks
like as we try to increase adoption of
chrome devices and browser within
artworks so I want you to go ahead and
introduce myself my name is Diana Chung
I run our customer success team for
Chrome enterprise and my team is
responsible for all of our post sales
deployment activities for enterprise
customers we just try to make sure that
our customers have a very smooth process
deploying the Chromebooks or Chrome
browser and just making sure that we
have our customers go through it as
smoothly as possible
and have a great experience and so today
I have with with me three of our
customers on stage and I'm gonna go
ahead and have them introduce themselves
but they're going to talk a little bit
about what Chromebook adoption looks
like for them so maybe Josh in the wall
go this way I'm Josh Chad I'm systems
engineer at Starbucks Coffee Company and
currently we have about 13,000
Chromebooks deployed in North America
so both Canada
the United States in all of our company
owned stores I'm Donna Tanaka and I'm
the managing director of our team member
collaboration enable men team what they
need to be financial and so what my
group does is we're about 50 team
members strong and we provide end-user
support on all devices as well as G
suite and and so with that we have about
700 750 pixel books within our
environment across our province and
Alberta hi everyone my name is Jason
tahini and I'm the director of IT 400
health care system we're a health care
system located in central New Jersey
we've been a chrome customer now for
about two years and we have a little
over 200 devices out there in production
currently with plans to do a lot more in
fact were licensed for almost a thousand
and we're gonna be rolling out a lot
more later this year well well welcome
everyone on the stage and now we're
gonna dig a little bit deeper so you
guys have a better understanding of
where they're at with their deployments
so maybe we'll just go down the row
again and talk a little bit about how
you're using Chromebooks
and where they're currently deployed
today yeah so as I mentioned before we
have at least one Chromebook and every
single one of our stores that are
company-owned and they're used primarily
by all the partners which is what we
call our employees to access things like
scheduling software information our
information portal a few other like
inventory tools cash management things
that are just basic operational tools
that everyone within the store has some
need to access and we need to be
financial we started our journey to
using Chrome as our key browser as well
as then introducing Chromebooks into our
environment as part of our G suite
implementation so as a company we made
the decision to move on to G suite in
December of 2016 and then we deployed
the full suite into our entire
organization in July 2000
17 and so during that journey we had
seconded 50 people which I'll talk about
more called G evangelists and at that
time we introduced the Chromebooks to
them so we had 50 Chromebooks within our
environment and you know they started to
gain a better understanding how to use
Chromebooks how to help our other team
members to use the Chrome browser and
from their onion we then gradually moved
into Pizza boats across our province and
now very my story is very similar to
Donna's we our entry point to the chrome
devices was through G suite and we went
live about two years ago with the G
sleep products includes Gmail we use the
Chromebooks for training and education
during that time we're really great we
kind of had this like mobile team that
went out we have a lot of physician
practices we're kind of in rural part of
Jersey I mean not really 30 minutes away
is not so rural but we still have rural
areas so a lot of our physician
practices you know it was we used it as
a tool to get out and train and educate
and work work very well we're also using
chrome NIT heavily it's we use it on our
helpdesk you know with the integration
with all DC looking at these sweet as a
platform and has worked very well for us
NIT and and just moving out out of there
out of IT where they're our
standard-issue laptops is starting to
deploy them as a standard issue laptops
so a new employee comes to the
organization you're gonna be getting a
Chromebook and it's it's it's you know
for us it was security we had to look at
what the strength of it is we felt was
his modern operating system it was
secure about the fall this is very
important in health care a lot of data
breaches that we have to challenge I had
to integrate with our Windows
environment as well very important and
we used VDI VMware horizon as that
product you can use Citrix as well I
know it works very well so we were very
very happy with it and we're gonna be
doing a lot more we want to move it out
to our clinical desktop so we want it we
have a tapingo solution called
healthcast and that we used you know
that we need to support that product and
I believe it's coming this quarter once
that's available then we're gonna get
chrome devices out to our clinicians and
and that we're real excited about that
I'm gonna hear about some future
printing we'll talk more about the
future plans as well but in fact let's
just kind of jump right in what did that
implementation process look like for you
in terms of getting chrome into your
environment and into the hands of users
sure so we we started with a proof of
concept and the important things like I
mentioned we're security right it had to
be easy to use we also were looking for
some cost savings in the r2 because I
was kind of the promise of it and on the
security front I mean it the promise has
worked out very well I mean we you know
we needed expensive software in our
Windows environment to deployed
encryption to take one example and the
fact that it comes by default in our
Chromebooks you know and also tying to
that patching and kind of those standard
things you need to do in a Windows
environment the chrome devices Auto
patch and do a very nice job of that we
really don't have to I don't want to say
it's set it and forget it kind of
insecurity but you don't ever want to do
that but it's it's giving us a good good
sense of confidence we did you know we
did about three months but just because
we were doing the security part of it we
wanted to integrate it into our
Microsoft environment as well for
authentication so you wanna make sure
users just using the same username and
password that they use the logins or
Windows computer make sure that work on
Chrome devices and so that that part of
it worked very well we also you know the
ease of use and want to understand we
kind of put it out to some of our
clinicians to kind of see hey what do
you think of this is gonna work pretty
well we actually created some power
users to help us with that process and
you know we got really good feedback it
was you know I would say that you know
we did a lot of training and education
in the beginning but I would say you
really don't I don't believe you really
need it I think I heard the numbers
about 1.5 billion Gmail users today so
having that you know and these are
chrome devices but having that
familiarity it's very similar right that
Google kind of keeps their feel that
they keep their products and it look and
feel very similar and I think that's
carried over into chrome and and it's
worked out pretty well in Josh maybe we
can talk a little bit about your
implementation process as well and yours
what were some of the challenges that
you experienced while you were piloting
it and then
out to the stores yeah I would probably
say the biggest challenges we had were
the logistics of just shipping a device
from a central location to about 10,000
different stores that are geographically
diverse on as well as giving it and
without having to do a lot of pre
configuration as well as implementing
the security that we needed so we had to
partner with with Google
augusto to write a custom app for us for
an out of box experience so when it did
actually get to a store they could go
through a very short setup process so
that we could on our side in ite
we could identify where that device is
so if the store calls in we don't need
them to read off a serial number or
something like that we can just look up
their location and find the effective
device the other piece was getting
client certificates on the device as
easy as possible and with that we also
used a product cloud path to integrate
in with our PKI so that we could during
the enrollment process provision
certificates onto that device for things
like Wi-Fi access and client cert off
for certain internal sites and I know I
remember when we were doing the
deployment initially there were a bunch
of security considerations that you guys
that you guys had to account for with
Starbucks maybe you can speak a little
bit about that as well the challenges
there yeah so one thing that we really
are we're careful of is we wanted this
to be a shared device so in a store of
anywhere from ten to a hundred partners
that work in there that no data is going
to stay resident on the device after the
sessions done as well as there's no data
from a store manager that's accessible
by a barista or someone else that they
don't need to see so that was a huge
consideration for us so we actually run
our Chromebooks in kind of an ephemeral
mode where every time they log off
every single thing about that session is
wiped from the computer so it maintains
security and a security posture and also
just a legal compliance posture that
works really well for our company thank
you and Donna your turn
we'll talk a little bit now we're moving
into more of the change management front
and Donna definitely led a huge effort
there for her particular implementation
so maybe you can speak a little bit
about what's required from a change
management perspective for chrome and a
bit of G sweet hair tied together for
sure and you know we went live in July
2017 and we have over 5500 team members
that's we call our employees that are
located across the province of Alberta
in Canada and we have over 300 locations
and so for us as we looked at how to
introduce chrome and implement G suite
across the province and help all of our
team members through the change learning
both the G suite toolset but then also
accessing Chrome browser we really took
a different look at it and how we can
help our folks and so really that for us
the three success key factors for that
was that we went out and we seconded 50
people from across of across our
province who he then called G evangelist
and what they were we're really folks
that were very diverse they were from
all regions of our province so it wasn't
just the big urban cities it was from
rural areas as well they were also
selected from people from as we are a
financial institution we had people from
our tellers or CSRs all the way up to
managing directors in corporate office
and what that did is really bring
together a diverse group of 50 people
who really we trained in a 30 day boot
camp on G sweet on Chrome on you know
how to help our team members and really
was about listening listening to our
team members and helping them through
the change and you know our key
man-otaur was no one was going to be
left behind because you know
we're an eighty-year-old startup company
and it's really about understanding that
we had people who have just started with
a company when we went live and we also
had people who've been in our you know
financial institution for over 30 years
right and so it's really understanding
that team members and people all you
know go through their own change
management curve in a different way and
so this was really key for us to be
successful as we went through the change
the following year we then introduced
pixel books into our environment and so
I would say the second success factor
there was we really focused on our C
suite and our executives first and you
might think wow that was pretty bold to
have them test your tools and you know
was that a lot of hand-holding and I
would say it wasn't they really found
the the tool easy to use and we thought
that if they would be onside that they
would be our biggest cheerleaders and
they were so it really became that they
came to us and said we want our teams to
have this we want our leaders to have it
and so right now most of our users are
our c-suite our executive and for sure
the branch managers located across the
province and then the third key success
factor I would say is right now we last
year we brought in-house all of our
technical supports our IT Help Desk and
so what we did is really grew a team of
who we call tech gurus so we don't call
them IT Help Desk we call them tech
gurus and they're really customer
service oriented and so they're really
there to help all of our team members
with chrome their questions as well as
pixel books and we utilize you know you
kind of heard this morning on the
keynote speaker we really utilize chat
for our team members to come in and ask
questions so we have chat room set up so
you can access our tech gurus we have
over 3,000 people already in our tech
chat room asking questions about how to
do this how to do that and then the
second part of that group we also have
product managers who provide support on
G suite and so we have a Google G suite
chat room as well
and so between those two forums we're
able to have a group of our own a to be
team members helping a to be team
members with their technology great and
I mean if you're too would you do
anything different would you have you
know if you were to do this again which
you do both together again G suite in
Chrome is it you know were there any
challenges to doing them so close
together yeah um we would definitely do
it together because as they were
learning how to access G suite it just
came in really easy to then introduce
Chrome so we would definitely do that
over again you know I would agree I
would agree with that you know we maybe
deploy more during Jesus because it
really was a move recognized it was good
there was good value there doing the
education but you didn't quite totally
get it so and it was a little bit longer
to deploy so yeah definitely would
deploy more when you what we're doing T
so you're moving in and then let's talk
about kind of the aha moment for you
guys when did you guys decide chrome was
the right way to go in terms of the
technology that you want to move your
org to maybe we'll just start down the
row again from Josh yeah I think for us
it was really during the pilot phase
when we were seeing kind of the issues
that they were the are our pilot stores
were calling in about and how simple
they were to solve because we eliminated
a lot of points of failure over a true
more traditional kind of like Windows
Device that we had previously so really
there were just very few things that we
had to spend time troubleshooting and it
freed up a lot more time for our
helpdesk analysts to work on much more
complex calls because they could solve
things much more easily or the stores
themselves could solve it without ever
having to call in and I think when we
would talked about it before you're
you're saying that there are there was
there are fewer calls coming in for
Chrome specifically and now it's just
basically you managing yeah it's pretty
much today we're in I think year four of
our deployment and
I'm the primary engineer and there are a
couple of analysts on my team that also
help support it as well as our help desk
operation but we have very few calls
very few things escalated to us on it's
probably less than 5% of the the work
that we have come in today just to do
any kind of support activities around
them because we introduced it with G
suite you know about how aha moment came
just as we saw people utilizing G suite
in in a much more collaborative fashion
and so my aha moment really keen we also
introduced and put in CFM's and all of
our meeting rooms at the same time and
so my aha moment was just how easy it
was to take in your Chromebook or your
pixel book into one of our meeting rooms
have this CFM right there and you just
connect to that to the meeting and so it
just just the ecosystem with having
CFM's pixel books and G suite all
together was my aha moment by saying
this is a great easy experience for team
members to use that's right and for us I
think there was there's a couple of one
was really where our departments are
coming to us for throne books yeah they
really they had seen him other people
had I mean they were just coming to us
for Chromebooks as well as I wanted to
use them with GCE applications so one
example was our patient safety Huddle's
leadership meets every daily the kind of
review any potential safety hazards in
the organization and we were using so we
use Chromebooks for that and Google
sheets so those two products to kind of
track what we're doing around patient
safety and it came to us right we didn't
have to sell it do anything like that
and another example was in our emergency
department they actually developed their
own internet site with Google Sites and
on Chrome devices and we were because we
were a large Microsoft SharePoint
customer at that prior to this so moving
to team team drive and the suite of
products with chrome yeah was was a part
of our goals was to consolidate all all
that data that we had out there and so
you know we were driving that project
then we also had departments coming to
us like the EE or they wanted to do
their own thing so that was that was
pretty nice and then NIT just yeah I
would agree on the management side it's
just incredibly
easy to manage especially on the
security side when whenever you hear
security is easy you know you kind of
question that a little bit right so but
it truly has been for us and seeing we
have sterilized on Chrome browsers as
well and the chrome devices that are out
there seeing that Auto patching work
you're running our report and see you
know Wells it's actually really working
and seeing that it is and by the way
we're doing it without any extra
software so it's included as part of the
platform which is very nice and and you
get these features you know by default
and the constantly innovating right so I
mean that's one of our main reasons why
we went with Google was because of their
ability to innovate and we felt they're
in the best best vendor to do that cloud
providers and so what's next for you for
all of you I guess in terms of your
chrome journey where you going with the
adoption are you rolling out more
devices
well definitely for us we're gonna roll
out more devices we have the the
partnership with healthcast and Google
once that's it's a really any day now
and healthcast is a tap and go solution
so it's kind of big in healthcare right
being able to move from computer to
computer and have your desktop session
move with you via tap and go via an
employee badge that so once that is
certified to run on Chrome which is
coming any day we're gonna be moving
that out to all our clinicians on all of
our anywhere we provide patient care and
it's gonna be we're excited about that
because you know right now yeah those
are Windows devices that are really not
do they're really like you sort of like
a kiosk think of that think about you're
not actually using the underlying
operating system on that device so
there's really no reason to have all
those people you know have that out
there I have to worry about you know
patching it for security and those and
all those kind of challenges that we
have so putting the chrome devices out
there we feel you know very confident
it's gonna give us a nice secure tool
out there for our clinicians that's not
gonna get in the way of what they do
every day and it's gonna be a lot easier
for IT demanders and what kind of you
don't to call headaches but just a
normal active headaches that you have on
managing a lot of devices yeah very
similar to rollout continue to roll out
pixel books and replace our window
environment and the laptops out there
right now and again just again
showcasing and advocating how easy a
pixel book is to use and just helping
people adopt
so again continuing to our roll up pics
of books within our environment Josh
yeah I'm for us where we're really just
looking at refining the overall
experience on our already our very large
fleet that's out there so really just
making it up maybe a little bit quicker
seeing what other use cases within the
store it makes sense to put on there and
different workloads as well as just
making access into that faster for
specific apps or functions that the
stores do today
and just overall just making it a really
easy experience for them and just
continue on that journey and then you
know for those for those members of the
audience that are here learning about
pixel are learning about Chromebooks for
the first time what kind of advice do
you guys have for customers who are
evaluating it for the first time yeah I
would say it's it's not it's very very
easy to deploy I mean your your your
user bases you know the training you
don't really need that much training
education you know we kind of thought we
did and we found that we did and so you
know and for us it's a modern operating
system so anytime we can for us a time
we do that in healthcare is the good
thing so depending on your industry I
mean I would just jump in I'll just do
it it's been it's worked out very well
for us yeah I I would echo that that I
would definitely support it yeah if you
would have seen a keynote speaker this
morning our CTO Wellington Holbrooke had
said you know we would never go back off
the G suite and so I would just add an
and on to that is that since we've gone
on to G suite and use the Chrome browser
and use our pixel books we even never go
back I would you know we are all about
looking at our team member experience
and using their technology and ensuring
that it's a seamless and it's a good
experience and so as you can imagine as
we you know run a bank is that we always
want our team members who are front
facing in front of our customers to have
technology that works for them great and
that is seedless and it's easy to use
because we always want our team members
to have a good experience with their
technology that just enables them to
provide a better customer experience and
so as we look at what those tools are we
we continue to look at Chrome
continue to look at pixel books and
saying how might we make this work for
them yeah I'm for it for us it's very
much just through that lens of security
and how easy it was to implement the
security how easy it was to do it scale
and to manage it all at scale so I mean
I manage all a lot of users I manage a
lot of devices and it's just very simple
once you're even even at pretty much
every stage - with a very small team
deploy a very large number these devices
very quickly
[Music]